[Music]
[Music]
hello happy Friday everyone surprised
Rob he's in a match we'll just get into
it real quick
day two battlefield 5 closed alpha in a
match are you putting conquest right now
conquests alright you're playing medic
play medic building some sandbags yeah
have you seen a lot of the buildings
yeah I've seen a lot of your sandbag
what do you you should stand back in so
what do you think of this uh I mean it's
kind of cool cuz it's like you have a
chance to reform I something that you
might use I feel like I'm not here I
told you this before the stream I've
never been a huge battlefield guy and
then more of a cod guy that's right
hate me that's okay but you know I was
playing around just now while you're out
and about walk resting up before the
stream and I had a couple minutes oh
they're still there though is that the
smoke nade though anyways it didn't feel
pretty good though
yeah and it looks really good it's
always looked pretty good though is is
the thing so yeah excited for the the
folks that are battlefield fans that are
coming looking to play this obviously
come October I think it is right yeah
I'll have to double-check your date for
you but um if you have a box you can
play a little earlier yeah close alpha
I'm sure there'll be an alpha beta all
that fun stuff so yeah I'm currently
playing on PC if you guys are curious at
all yeah it looks real good
it's real good you can't adjust any of
the settings quite yet though if you
want it to go if you want to see full
ultra settings it's kind of just doing
like an auto adjustment I think so
I don't know it'd be cool to see this
max out because I'm sure it looks even
better upon final release
that's interesting are you just saying
that no I'm just looking at something
else kind of moderately worrying have
you seen this Panzer fast it's pretty
good
you mean $50 fifty million dollar shot I
just kill him arch there
arc arc arch Jesus Christ Jesus happy
Friday yeah happy Friday curious for
those on YouTube are you guys seeing
this alright hopefully you are you got
it I like how so sorry my my worries has
to do with like YouTube's console you I
think telling us oh your current bitrate
is low I recommend a bit rate however
you should stream at a lower bitrate
it's like what no we had a make sense oh
no to health is good now oh you know
what it it just gives a second because
you're playing twitch exactly no no so
what it is is uh is when it does the
live loop when I have the live loop
going on YouTube thinks it's not a good
signal more or less right and so then
it's like oh your stream health is not
so great because this loop is not
representative of anything that we're
gonna stream right sort of it's probably
not the best way to put it but anyways
we're good thank you addict Thank You
Eric green what's up hello / the big
drowning second day watching great
livestream yesterday can you try to get
knocked back by an explosion we'll love
to see the animation maybe maybe he or
she's referring to like an explosion of
light of a different soldier oh my god
maybe I don't know what happens to you I
don't ya just ragdoll right I guess like
I think because one of the cool things
about this game is you see a lot of like
aesthetics and animations on like other
soldiers like high knees and snow like
we kind of watch them or like if you
sprint into a wall they'll like throw a
God so I tried that just now hip-fire I
gotta aim that sighs no I think you
should just switch your pistol yeah
that's what worked for me at the time
but like I said getting warmed up
getting that brewski Friday brewski
going it'll only enhance his play that's
how I see it that's how it my first beer
is always good yeah then there's
definitely diminishing returns
absolutely um I think Hammond said a
long time ago they did a reality check
about like you know drinking and driving
so it was like you know them drinking
and then then play Mario Kart Oh
interesting and there's definitely a
point at which you fall off and you
don't get better and you're probably
drunk driving right
this is good yeah you might want to make
it yourself in a bit sorry to backseat
Drive here no that's what we do what I
want to hear but yeah I'm in the chat
checking you guys out thank you guys all
for tuning in of course second stream of
the day our second battlefield stream in
the last two days
pretty hot fun action yeah I got stick
with my squad so I can get revived more
so I think bad I think they fixed the
squad stuff yeah because you guys are
kind of playing together outside earlier
so yeah I think one of our goals the
stream oh I am squad leader perfect so
let's try to do that V rocket yeah man
you're running out tickets I don't know
how far you know yeah my points about if
not well if not this how many points you
have okay you do see yeah like I got to
get another 20,000 maybe doable
possibly let's start being a team player
then
yeah so telling them where to go what's
what is this right here
hey I'll fast let's just hang here and
defend you got to get out of [ __ ] also
you guys seem rusty yeah a little bit
you know I I don't even have rust cuz I
didn't really ever play look at that box
is floating in the air remember closed
alpha sound good
sticking with the squad hopefully get
some revives I can definitely revive
mm-hmm I'm real good at that
let's I remember yesterday watching you
guys like you stabbed the guy in
multiple times got him on the boot you
stabbed a guy multiple times with your
syringe and I didn't do anything and
then finally it registered yeah oh I was
like stabbing him in his wiener
right yeah what's up walkie-talkie Nilla
hello anvil gaming even though anvil one
game even though I see you everyday in
the chat and in real life not everyone
plays hardcore Evanier I was never a
huge fan of hardcore modes I liked them
occasionally
that's a smoke grenade isn't it you've
been doing that since yesterday well I'm
gonna throw whatever I can you can
you'll hurt them a little bit or give
you cover to for getting on the point or
whatever but what I was gonna say is a
thing you change your grenade is that
even a thing no there's not much
customisation they give you the bare
bones here I can okay
it just takes a second get up you
goggled man oh crap
nice yep
you might have to revive that guy again
yeah teammates I got oh my lord he's
bleeding okay he's fine
oh that that guy's just old okay can
revive him again this is perfect [ __ ]
stealing no no this is best real life
right there dude that was pretty good
that's that's how you get the points you
get you kill some you revived the same
guy that died to revive him again use
them as bait you know
yeah just keep reviving one guy he's
like I'm not really having fun David
Poland asks at GameSpot Diaz does this
improve the Battlefield franchise I mean
I haven't played enough of it but also
realizing it's only multiplayer right
now right so it's hard for I would
assume it's harder for you to maybe
answer that question in full but how
does it feel feel multiplayer wise if we
were just to speak about multiplayer it
feels pretty good man I love them the
movement the gun the shooting feels
great yeah we like in that sliding or
whatever those are the highlights like
but crawling and yeah it feels good man
like I still you do like a prone right
and then you can like wait oh you can't
turn around right to have oh there it is
oh it looks kinda weird
my legs so there here's my legs here's
my body it looks it looks what is going
on close down it could be a factor of
cranking up the fov any idea for the
open beta no not not of one right now
that I know I could try looking that up
though I'm not sure if that's like
public information or not yet but I was
seeing if you're asking me that you
might not they might not be so and so or
look like it but there's a lot of debris
so I could be absolute liar
Dora
oh so they have different code names for
the points instead of like Delta Charlie
and Bravo
what was that you know I almost say the
one thing you get good at in terms of
what is this sorry what in battlefield
is I checked a lot of corners yeah and I
don't normally check how did you get the
beta we're in close alpha I mean we were
fortunate enough to you know obviously
work here at GameSpot so like affords us
the ability to get into some of these
play sessions so another really cool
thing about this game is the ammo
scarcity it's like you only really have
like two magazines yeah I realized that
too I was like oh crap I'm running out
of bullets better have somebody write
7:00 a.m. oh yeah what am i what am I
getting hit with was there like fire
like he's happy yeah maybe some scenario
grenades
yeah so it's cool to like pick up ammo
and like you know work as a team it's
kind of incentivizing that a lot yeah
maybe you're like you have someone that
will supply you with ammo right yeah I
mean I'm sure that was kind of the case
in the past too but now more than ever
yeah wave wave very much so still good
still good you kind of wish there was a
kill cam just cry because I would like
them to have known yeah well you got
like bomb did I look like a bomb for
sure come on Arthur you guys stay alive
here alright there's about a hundred
they have about 80 tickets left you're
about ten thousand off of the or like
nine thousand one it's not a sure win
but we're looking good
yeah but it's I don't know if you'll get
to be one is all I'm saying
and they're bombing us
a lot of planes in the sky let's do
something this right here some more the
building get them points trying to get
the the v1 big jabroni that'd be pretty
cool when do you think the full bill
will come out hard to say probably
closer to it game release sorry to cut
you off no is this doing anything points
yeah it just gave you 20 though no did
it well I don't know if the 20 that you
get on the middle of the screen like
that like I don't know if that adds to
your running total there is this world
war 2 I mean it's Second World War 2
mm-hmm what's up lil Vox
what is the quick question it's just
send it yeah send that question yep send
it along the full beta will come out I
would probably say August do you think
so yeah that's too much yeah I guess so
like a probably like our latest
September maybe like late August or
something mm-hmm feel like it should
only multiple betas last night they do
so if we're comparing to battlefield one
they knew just this they're basically
doing the exact same lineup I think as
they will without field one which was
like you know you had that one map and
reveal at e3 there oh you have that same
map from the most part that transfer
vote transfers over to a the same
basically the same map which is this too
like crap closed alpha which is this and
then it'll probably be a period of time
closed beta for a week and then run the
next week after that will be open beta
forever okay
do you think this game could support
low-to-medium hardware hard to say yes
very good
oh he's right in front wait what
he was right in front of you but now
he's dead there's a bunch of guys here
huh
they're coming yeah they were coming up
the hill nor the flag oh they're
probably yeah there's another one back
covered no uh friendly fires off
obviously I could hear that Oh bye oh
I'm reloading if you were curious
through this right hands we were so that
was pretty good though I mean like for
the two of you like okay you guys want
that's good I was like I felt like a can
you level a whole town if you wanted to
like to a degree I think yeah like I was
gonna say sword oh no you can't cuz like
if you get a tank and you try to like
they were showing off a lot of
destruction destructible environments
the tanks like you if you really want to
go like square middle into a house like
it'll stop you like you can only do like
the outside walls for the most part okay
like that can be rebuilt then yeah like
exactly like if you saw him that just
where we were that staircase I don't
think you can take down okay will you be
able to fly bombers like 43 eyes are
Mitchell yeah I think so yeah let's see
speaking of flying bombers let's start
off in one how about that
can you Nate enable it Eric I don't know
can you enable friendly fire I don't
know maybe in a heart that would be a
marker oh yeah yeah harcourt mode is
like but i don't know if that was even
in battlefield one maybe later on I kind
of fell off that game but I don't I
don't think it was is that normally more
of a card thing camera I don't think
battlefield really had that much of it
uh I think Cod has it in hardcore yeah
so you know somebody took it
have you been primarily playing medic
yeah cuz I like this gun a lot okay
or else what shut up no you're good I
I'm just curious about the playing the
classes and what our spread looks like
in the office that's all I mean I'm sure
you could potentially run this on a more
medium type a console if you just lower
settings
assuming you're okay with that
but I haven't tried so whoa Oh
interesting
would you like that that's that's they
like show that off in the trailer like
the trailer yeah like really threw me
for a loop because it looked kind of pre
pre done for sure it's not necessarily
of the funny thing when we were talking
about it was when they were adding all
the points and things like that and it
just the did you I made it like kind of
like a little bit more cheesy because I
was like there's no way that's how it's
gonna look like right in the game right
but I mean I guess it's the like
representation of like this is what your
game experience should feel like yeah
yeah
can you play black ops poor no we don't
have it I'm sure once we get a beta or
alpha or an event that will definitely
scream in it I will definitely play me
some black ops we're going right there
that tank I don't know if has a tank but
there's definitely a person to that like
running the bottom left of you sorry
good I don't even know where you get
shot from maybe down like through that
way yeah
where are you buddy sniping he's in a
little sniper's nest wow you guys have
like almost all the points what the hell
is the other team doing freaking nothing
dude yeah obviously how you facili sites
f oh man oh you're gonna challenge oh he
was better you didn't know that he has
sniper I did okay like this that's why I
was like you're gonna challenge now that
he knows where you are yeah sniper games
guys sniper games sniper mind games
although in reality even though that's
not what this is about that guy would
not have reach allenge but in a video
game setting I definitely saw that guy
coming back out challenge Rob well
wouldn't you if you guys never there's a
guide to revive we got you come on dang
it what's wrong oh no I'm sorry dude
yeah says he's a good medic filled with
lies no yeah I'm surprised it's not just
like a hockey though if you were a medic
instead of having this 48a switch to the
syringe oh you know I mean like I do it
instead of like oh here press e or
something you Auto pick up med parens on
you by the way mo fuzz is in your powder
really right great two syringes
last delta go after also are you li
squad lead I am it's wobbly so time to
try to get that be one rock a swim you
got a tough little break in the open
you're fine Arthur's down - over there
all right squaddies let's do this right
Arthur
yep
still good you seem to have watch out
see good thing picked up Arthur okay
thanks for saving my life another guy
javis your job you chubby so there it is
easy to revive but you do have to have
the syringe out obviously but yeah
bigger right yeah I get it though Morse
where eat we have less people on our
team alpha and beta or sorry whatever
the code names are I don't think they're
alpha just original develop Betty oh
there's another guy that needs your
squad
Bugsy Malone this is gonna be rough Oh
Oh nada
gasps okay you're good he doesn't see
you ruff yeah squad wipes and we revived
buddy
whoo that's that new movement look at
Rob and his patients Antone is a and
Foxtrot Oh get out of my way you smoked
it though yeah I did probably like good
smoke I'll go attack now well we in here
lolene system
I like this bridge design how there's
like two layers to it oh my god those
hands are fast crap he's behind us throw
the bomb away
oh that was apparent you can pick those
up yeah it had a prompt but it was ever
so slight and I think it was only when
you were in the right direction for it I
saw it but then you pivoted I was like I
think that's a good note yet you're dead
Gigi nice place as black bro thanks
thanks black fro wait anybody can revive
I thought you had to be a medic no no no
so the yes - no so you can revive no
matter what class you are anyone in your
squad that guys crashing so I can't I
can't if I was if I was a medic I
couldn't revive if you weren't a medic
you wouldn't be able to revive it that
guy right in front you correct ethics
oh yeah me likey you folder Rob through
a smoke hey man you're doing it for your
teammates little little do you know oh I
can revive that guy what an idiot
now we're gonna go save our friend it's
called double the points here right knee
open you're good you got uh huh oh you
beat air into it he's trying to revive
not here we're squad leader Aaron give
us all the points while we're we got a
long ways it's okay it's early in the
match I should probably be doing more
squad stuff yeah oh there's another guy
too revived there if you can get to him
oh lordy I thought I thought you were
gonna go for the big hero revive there I
don't know like he saw me right yeah I
would have been he would he mailed me
most definitely play in the corner
though yeah he was it's amazing what
sleep does for Rob's play is what Eric
Green says yeah oh here he goes
ladies and gents this is the real Rob
that we know yeah you know what I
haven't this is like I don't know like
this had this the flying hasn't been
feeling that great really yeah I think
it's just because it's alpha cuz I
remember be if one close off I have the
same deal where it was like kind of just
janky some latency sand like rubber
banding on flying and stuff but so
here's a question if you're a squad
leader do you think it's good to get
into like a vehicle like a plane well
Erik as long as I'm doing stuff like
this you didn't do it didn't actually
tell well I see well as long as I'm
doing stuff like this there you go there
you go go to be will be in the sky will
watch over you from above and hope for
the best
good luck to you
this is squadmate let's do some dive
bombing whoo that's a guy back home I
you the world is your oyster no that's
our please give us bf5 alphago's
unfortunately I don't have it to give
out you made it we may get some clothes
alpha that's or closed beta down the
road but I can't guarantee guarantee
that oh look
see guys yeah I see good jump out yep so
good
nailed it shake it probably did help us
go for it or Antwon oh I'm fine
where's the tank wasn't it reading chat
the STG definitely needs to be nerfed
yeah it's Opie we should we should check
it out then why she's still there that
guy's been in that little corner must be
a good spot oh yeah okay was that your
chat you're on chat your chat you're
still on chat I'll just say it don't
know what it means
yeah Oh was that a guy oh whatever
too late I hope not waited too long yeah
nobody's showing got you your medic dude
you can sit okay oh come on
oh these guys should pick me up again
right I mean they're medics anvil one
gave me says it looks like pork Valdez
from the air
Jay or four charges also saying it does
look like pork Valdez bring them bad
company to vibes great thanks guys
next team should we yeah wait oh he
didn't bring you to get you up no say
give Erin some commands where should we
go
it's good D is this is D yeah it's good
yep understood everything he said
like it's a sniper heaven right now I am
I think you're gonna guess tonight are
your snipers oh man everyone's a medic
on this team I feel like it's fine oh
[ __ ] oh he's alive in there
rob is a cold player
here long-forgotten
here are you giving away keys no we're
not unfortunately there's definitely a
name I saw a name there so be careful
like a little UI thing popped up good
shot
thank you for that call-out I'm like the
guy like you're the sniper and I'm the
other guy that tells you like win degree
and recon distance and scout sure
whatever that is
I only know an ocular guy yeah I only
remember because of like what was that
shooter the movie shooter Mark Wahlberg
and then his buddy gets like mowed down
the guy that was his scout or whatever
or the recon yeah that's me I'm gonna
get oh you might be good cuz Aaron Aaron
is around there right just like to kill
this dude Oh complete squad wipe rough
stuff but that might have been the only
place they're spawning oh no one's at a
spotter spotter thinking medev 7 yeah
definitely you can tell I'm the military
I'm that guy the binoculars
who are you go away I felt really close
yeah I think he's behind the wall that
you're at Granada F
Oh everybody yeah their mama she's still
Luke Johnson also same spotter air clean
spotter a kujou low spotter six storm
spotter yep sighs sounds like a spotter
sounds like a spotter am bill one gaming
wants to know was this all pre destroyed
or did some of it some of the
destruction happened during the match
some of it was paid pre destroyed during
buildings for sure that's Integra a lot
of the stuff near well goes back and
forth but like for like the I think was
is it C or E itseif that's like all like
for the most part structures that you
can destroy oh [ __ ] what's wrong are the
graphics settings all on high you're on
unable to tell you can't even see yeah
it's just like auto detection so this
looks like it was all built
you could put up sandbags - right yeah
let's go to F after your next Seth you
should check how far along you are
although I have my doubts that you're
gonna get man hey maybe you can almost
get that tank Oh or plan oh you're right
good call
Oh minor up my god only you had more
ammo oh my that was a dream right there
you got two guys I had a machine gun
that was that was your cell division
dark zone moment right that was like
seven dudes car myself kinda left this
point oh my god let's they're coming
back all right
oh my God look how many freakin dudes
they are is that what's going on they're
just all coming for this haunting next
point and your team is kind of far away
I guess Aaron's picking them off from
the side ooh I don't know you guys are
good you wrapped around but they're all
going to do right now for sure when will
it come out if we're talking about the
actual game it'll come out in October if
you're Tonto
the likely closed or open beta that we
don't know see ya well done do you
switch classes or just guns switch
classes okay oh this is where I want to
be yeah
fighting for D
we'll watch out I saw that guy right
yeah no Jenna lay down with my bipod
going who's it by potted I know ya cuz
I'm aiming down sights
oh god I'm fairly sure that's why
Dora the explora we have Dora the
explora
okay you got smoked as cover
really 97
oh wait that's not that's not it was a
suppression hit nadir said you look like
Tim Robb I just saw that yeah I've never
gotten that so thanks I don't know why
Backstreet Boys is coming up but
someone's saying a lyric ain't nothing
but a heartbreak your crappy news
Tim Robbins you know Green Mile right
Shawshank joshing Sasa this is getting
frustrating this is Swampy's swampy 'us
nuts that's a good name real swampy all
right that's it I really like medic yeah
you should just play medic play what you
know okay
besides squad leader oh that's how that
guy he was on the chase
what's up Nathan
what's up Nathan he said things Swampy's
those things ten out of ten names
catastrophic all right well on Aaron
here surprised no one has brought up
Chris Evans dead
yeah me too what about cap old cap
America cap
I've gone for a big shot here yeah I've
been known to pull off but oh hey how
are you oh and he gave me ammo that's
that's teamwork mm-hmm that's the dream
work no it's how the dream works
hi try reinforcements I mean we can try
the tank but we're trying to get that v1
what is this oh is it take a shoot
shooting us oh that was good it did I
have to I have to say I thought you had
him in the in the head there but playing
like a jackass well he just had a sniper
hey maybe I gotta hang out with my team
Eric looks like a unicorn swimming and
cloud filled with chocolate and wine a
wonderful thing I don't what I don't
understand what okay this guy
nailed it how's the guy that killed you
and now you can revive the other guy oh
oh good little scooter nobody waiting
waiting do you got you with the SDG
though that med pack doesn't help you
though right does seem like it did
overall thoughts on alpha asks Ryan
foster I don't know man I think I think
it the shooting feels good
the movement feels good and that's like
those are like the highlights I could
say like I I think there's a I'm singing
there's quite a few bugs but that's a
given
like I had a bug or whenever like twice
when I ejected from the plane behind
enemy lines or like the the slaughter
war where you call it a like refused to
let me spawn again I had to quit yeah
you don't have to understand Erik it's
the freaking deep man deep okay someone
said oh it's oh my goodness the heels
Philip O'Neill really wants that v1
rocket even gave us new rocket emojis
dude we wanted to I think I think you
might have a chance though he'll feel
pretty good about it
let's go let's go for seat off that
guy's dead you could revive him
oh no I mean to do that you call it in
No
you're a 30000 okay 9000 away plenty of
tickets left I think we'll be fine as
long as you do some of these jackets and
razzed those guys to your left you got
it
horace on guy let me get him jesus nice
you got a capture there you go oh wow
dangerous that's how that's how they do
it in the real wars don't get your
friend yeah I got a shot in the leg on
purpose now you're dead - medic yeah be
a team player dude well technically now
you'll know for next time to rub up
against that wall instead of just
willy-nilly gameplay looks harder it
looks like like you need ammo etc yeah
ammo is all about some plain gameplay oh
we just did that but then we can do some
more we get less points that way right
analyst oh there's so many people there
see you dude
you know what to do I'm gonna I'm gonna
get a uh let me get mp40 we're oh man we
are getting rekt now I know I noticed
this we're getting the rekt
the Saving Private Ryan moment Rob get
good Oh God there's two there's two
there's two I'm like I'm like hey I just
watched your squad you know playing like
I gotta here playing like I would if it
was caught running good baby except
coming back after you dies a lot slower
that's for sure
what's up Christopher Moreno you did the
opposite facepalm dude guys don't hate
me alright is that hit that hard he's
encouraging I hadn't encouraged a major
target is he really no no but for real
we're the V books that you know
fortnight go spend your V bucks there
this is kind of fun who is help a little
slide oh yeah crash oops so close a 4000
Rob focus focus fight win v1
yeah it helps where you at where was
this Butthead at what he's strong me
again I'll just over here well that says
spot there hiding in our last time
there's a guy here Dean okay that's fine
that's yeah it's totally fine
what I didn't see it I know but look at
Mugsy dude this is so Mugsy here big
plays Mugsy here going for the hot flank
yeah he's totally oh we goin for the hot
flank - did you give me ammo
I'll give you health oh we're going for
the big flame oh we're gonna we are
gonna big flank @b we're gonna get the
biggest flank steak no new map now yet
now oh yeah oh you can capture from down
here apparently that's hilarious no
wonder they're standing there last time
in that corner oh yeah
and that's why you should stay in the
corner yeah but I was trying to up the
ladder
we're shooting oh yeah Carrodus here it
is Aaron nice dude yeah hurry up hurry
up do it hurry up we gotta get out here
nailed it
all right we're getting some caps back
nice that was very good yeah very good
back in the game back in the game huh
now I'm back I thought I saw a guy that
guy I know you won't know unless you
take a shot
nope wasn't the guy of sandbag that's
sandbagging son of a B yeah he's
shooting from above time for another big
flank Oh mugsy's down Mugsy there's a
guy coming I'm gonna get a shot okay and
get it for the team
you did it further mama typing right
popo's Oh back there back there
hey yeah you're good smart get those
points you know it was that bad got it
hey you said I think you're good now I
just saw a red name come up at a oh that
guy might be a bad guy up
dick I couldn't a hundred percent tell
because Aaron died well quick here I
guess
oh there's someone else here it's just
you and him Mugsy what the hell was that
what no you're good yeah
Oh revive that guy my head sticking out
oh good a grenade
nice you might have be one possibly it's
very possible that you have the view one
Rock a ya know that jump though I know
right I'm definitely not saying that the
dirty yeah I can't try - alright v1 it
did it end where we do oh so I have to I
have to spot it spotter up then where
are we doing it at ah because those
[ __ ] sucked okay
didn't a mess with the robbed cat might
as well call you a bobcat
shadoobie that's where you said you
wanted to do it I don't know you do you
man oh this guy's together way dude I'm
a doctor to you guys let's make sure we
got enemies
look at you
I just fear it's just it's just not all
run alright we should do it soon huh
yeah yeah maybe cuz you good there okay
let's just get that bridge
give me maybe Aaron will get you up yeah
it's a chain it's for medics you can't
stop us
I'm there he died in mid watch watch his
Aaron dies to get you two it's like do I
do it
do I dare to OC smoke that's a smart
medic whoa what just happened
alright we're calling it in
did you call it there no no no where's
the rocket will we see it nope we at
least hear the explosion that's it there
it is hey y'all would you like to see
some footage of us calling in a 1o
it's like the other teams started trying
or we stopped trying or something oh
that's a tank
do you wanna rock it whoo yeah mm-hmm
you see that big explosion that was v1
it's this will be epic
hope it was that big F what's up game DX
letter cache topic
enjoy your meeting lol well next match
says right yeah suck it what you got I
believe I got out of that house weird
you didn't pick up the health that time
I don't know if maybe the medics don't
know he picks it up that's weird oh
please get good after I leave oh we
definitely will get good catastrophic a
Google reviewer you can review Google I
find that pretty interesting the search
Google search well he called one in
right we did lol they got their second
wind
yeah I don't know they just started
taking points over or we stopped holding
them
Oh interesting traded traded or some
other guy called you potentially what's
up TJ looks like we're oh watch out
you're getting revived in a really bad
spot okay sick sick sick sick sick sick
puff of wind whip whip whip all right
one win one loss called in a v1 rocket
couldn't see it do anything fortunately
surprised we wands as a tree at the top
left
Oh some guys got a shark's icon
shoutouts to that guy sharks as in the
San Jose Sharks
it's okay Rob to heal you have to get
out of combat ah make sense Thank You
Loki Doki oh good
let's get a tank you say I just made
CAPTCHA and holds the objectives as many
as
over that see dr. Dutton
hi fern I shot possibly
Wow dude
hello from Romania hi hello mate m8 well
hello
so what's up with grand operations is it
on the same map its what uh yes it's the
exact same man holy God
still good barely Danny no it knocked my
tracks off I think be shooting at dude
no that's Aaron yep fixed fixed where
should we go next let's what's Bobcat
you're the squad leader again so
hopefully we get another v1 that's the
goal here I'll teach that guy
come on come on
Aaron protect the vehicle oh that's not
good Aaron said I'm out of here
we won't make it out of this you see the
guy though right that's hands on you
oh six six life no problem no problem no
problem
we're gonna get out of here mo fuzz is
down I'm not an act oh why don't you get
you with
don't worry we'll put all this rubble
back up skirmish how's the gameplay is
it's smooth that's okay that's pretty
good beta production hi guys how ya'll
do
how y'all's day been pretty good Friday
weekend's about to start we're gonna
have a weird break in the middle of next
week
cuz the fourth of July we had food
trucks today that was good
Robins having a brewski I said I had a
case d it was not very good I went with
the safe burger choice also because that
was the shortest line all right
Caesar
holy God all right we're getting Caesar
back hopefully interesting how do we not
have to see what we can see are you not
gonna try to take see you rob I am
taking see yeah you know it's counting
down it's because there's someone else
here I'm assuming man right down there
in that house doing this you really want
this to for two special huh
he's not making another 50 mil that's it
that's a funny thing I just tweeted is
Rob gonna make another 50 mil and it
certainly doesn't look that way
nice
oh what a marksman with that pistol real
low health there nice medev enjoy that
hello I love Alvin
Albania Reuben de Leon says hey do you
remember when you knocked that plane out
of the sky of the rocket yeah he was
trying to do it again hey I don't know
what just happened
thanks Aaron he senses danger let's just
go with what I know how does the
gunfight slash movement feel usual bf
frostbite physics
yeah for the most part I don't know like
it it it feels a little slower in
general as far as the big the moment a
moment I got it now like for the most
part it does oh wow wow that was lucky
like it's it's it feels very much the
same I think when it comes down to it
but I don't know I'm enjoying it like
these red barrels are you switch back to
medic yeah I didn't shave this one with
the other gun oh [ __ ] it's pretty tough
when they got you like pinned in now I
feel like I don't know how many capture
points you have maybe one or two yeah
what's up beta thought it was supposed
to be a Royale I mean that's only one of
the potential game types of which they
haven't even like gone into that much
detail about okay nice guy capture aaron
has left your squad big plays
Here I am big play Rob here
let's take it dude
the only thing my building is at six
you're so out in the open you know like
don't worry I'm gonna lay some sandbags
here I think there's a guy that's coming
oh my god alright hopefully we got be
here nice work all by yourself
all by myself dude no problem no problem
how do you register for the Alpha don't
know about that one what was a question
how do you register for the Alpha I
don't know if you can yeah
we're given a code to use
let's move on that's good to me
let's get that come back let's get a
gunfire nice work mop it up oh he's
definitely gonna come back here
don't mind me here guys just doing some
home repair fortifying for the winter
think you got her wait oh yeah d-flat
cannon them make the call your squad we
are Dora but only says on it Lucas
you drop any free keys now there's one
to your left that's why they call me the
spotter thanks guy mm-hmm a lot of
people write to your life again
Oh a whole squad in front of you the
quad was coming I could smell it oh it's
Raquel stop oh oh oh yeah dude look
who's back back again
Robbie's bag probably does on the hella
awesome that hammer did mm-hmm
must have been can I call you I don't
know but you're doing really well though
okay you're like almost halfway in the
game it's probably only like a like a
quarter of the way through you're trying
to you getting that thing I was thinking
about it
Oh a stay at a we're saying yeah yeah I
guess I am
nice work you're right Oh yep good
scoochie he's gotta come finish you off
though oh he's he's a silly man oh
there's a grenade nice oh man Rob's
feeling it it's not fired
he's won a kill away from it NBA Jam
fire that the data that is good ah
jinxed it
jinxed it do you do you have an
alternate do you have a handgun - yeah I
know yeah that's what's cool about the
ammo scarcity is that it really
reinforces you to like pull that out why
should I go I want to go back here oh
but you're doing so hot do you have a
code now I don't know we don't
Oh back to alpha huh
payback go go go that sounded bad this
guy
Thanks are you using mp40 mm-hmm yep
aku he is using the mp40 there's two of
them
Oh hashtag worth worth it's okay work
respect worth worth worth as a matter
double you could have saved they could
have saved your friends sooner I've seen
dead I haven't seen that execution dead
they were like hey I'm gonna get the
execution instead that's fine pop up
okay let me open up for you thank you
you got it all right let's just go with
these boys here and the D split D dudes
Oh f you good surprise
some guy the freakin Panzerfaust just
still guys to your left up there
potentially yep
nice
oh all damage she just shot him from up
there yeah I should have it's all good
someone will revive you I feel like
maybe not
I should stick with my squad Thunder
how's the match going enjoying the game
yeah Rob's having a good match right now
so far we're gonna try to get a b1 and
hopefully see the b1 this time no
promise yeah no promises we've had a
couple good flanks smoked out to your
left for sure time to give him the old
bum rush they'll never know he's just
probably still 80s in right now like a
like a chump
god I hope he is
just be still 80s ting like a chump
better are they
monkeys good though
well they're back here
get up Julius we can get in a plane in a
bit your last squad guys you might want
to yeah or no no it's okay someone
spawned on you too so it was actually
pretty good
no they took Dean they took Dora
they didn't take Dorai yet not nuts my
Dora nine really wants to get in the
plane but we're trying to get that v1
rocket yeah what is that guy he's in a
good spot figure it out you can heal
yourself
alright kind of got and crash or
something guys over here will arrive in
a second if you have guts
gotcha Mac come on
oh he's under is he shooting under the
thing oh he is that's such a good spot
that is a good spot keep it alive and he
kind of
so you're saying you want more gameplay
audio comrade
you dome did that guy though
Muggsy all right we're flanking big
flank from Big Rob I'm gonna use a
ladder okay such a rebel losing Bravo or
beta or whatever B is called right now
but sure but get up [ __ ] you got your
the last squad remember big flank baby
not so big no yep like I was being I was
being cute there oh no worries
comrade then thanks I love from Belgium
thanks timer thanks for watching from
Belgium
frickin getting a plane but you can't
huh no I mean there's no planes
available I could wait that's fine also
look at your points I think oh no that's
not good time to look at points
ah okay your price tool first I'm not
playing with my squad says people
work with your squad nah man they don't
call him Rob cat for nothing he's a lone
Bobcat it wasn't that guy that killed
you right the guy that jump shot cuz
that was some real Cod stuff right there
dude
now he knows better see how I got wiped
there yeah all right here's your plane
yeah yeah we got it aplay there you go
I think there's DUIs
we got some bombs
get bombed
[Music]
so I'll have anti-tank cannons they're
like high caliber guns
have some more bombs nope someone's in
your spot with you is that something
because she can know the same plan
murder
I thought I had the different plane
what do you see goose
sucks I have to go Reef to get more
bombs out back my base
so it's nice and compared to be f1 is
like right now we're pairing I was
unable to repair and like in the air and
be up on now you can do both which is
nice I was kind of ridiculous
oh you're a bomb come on that was
unfortunate so you have 35,000 me about
five five to six thousand more and
you'll get that uh v1 rocket how's weird
I saw you repair but then anything give
you actual like life back
oh there's some nice Aaron get out Odin
saved she said if you guys didn't know
robbed flies with a controller should
just kept going almost on night 107 to
404 you guys have way less tickets but I
mean I think you'll get to the v1
looks awesome from your mom Hawk pit no
I'm just gonna read the other one going
back to old reliable I'm gonna do a
stall class how that goes okay you're
300 away from I can try the flame
thrower tank it's up to you but you're
like literally 200 points away from the
v1 rod yeah all right there there's one
guy to your right god that's really low
might have been killed there though
nailed it I really hope that was there
we have 16 bullets just a fire
behind ya oh you killed that other guy
though huh you definitely have the VF
for v1 sorry you can decide when you
want how's that although you're running
on time
don't listen to no there's no codes
I think closed alpha is until Tuesday
friend Cisco no did I accidentally get
the tank yeah oh my god it's such a
finicky thing I'm trying to like let go
the mouse alright well then we get the
show off the tank as well do it you have
26 tickets left so no point to hold on
to it
converse says I work at a brewery and
get free beer but your job with closed
Alfa's and III trip perks or more lid
yeah I mean you don't have a terrible
job or perks either if you think about
it just depends this is the flamethrower
tank no I don't think it is I know but
you're getting a long budget whoa down
walk it how do I need it now that you
called it in it's definitely that is it
just on Rails it has to be then huh I
mean maybe it's just different for each
side
did it you did pretty well though I mean
for your team
no that wasn't a tiger I thought was
though it's a tiger
he said Sturm tiger stream we're getting
game great game play keep it up see how
we doing time we are we probably have
enough time for one match ok one more
match
we started at 2 right yeah we open time
for one more Michael I call it after
that good yeah feel better feeling
better
maybe what was your score on that one
can't show it anymore anymore I'm pretty
sure you're not 5 I was like I was
checking in my team I believe yeah let's
try the tank again pretty sure you had
the one that you had to buy though or
the you know earn mmm I think someone's
got the tank before me that's cool
all right here we go back to the old old
reliable where are we going for tell
them where to go Rob this time we're
getting the v1 rocket and watching it Oh
someone got one WT Lucas got tank or I
think so yeah I try this out and show
this
oh they're getting be sounded go for
something no let's go see let's go to
the D yeah let's go to the deed no
friendly that you just ran by hmm okay
have you guys played the New World War
three game there's a World War 3 game
yeah no I know about it though no we
have not
behind that mounts there are a lot of
guys here it definitely took these so
they're probably gonna try to hold it
hold it down guy to res over there oh I
meant the other guy but that work soon
[ __ ]
oh you're good you're good you're good
you're good
did you see that I have my Oh did you
did he melee him I don't know I but I
was funny was I invited him again right
or no no he's gone what I was funny was
I had you butted to him with your gun
yeah cuz I last-second try to pull out
my gun instead you use my gun but it
will revive him yeah that was a pro tip
no way smoke bomb
you can't see me John Stone pilot 4/20
says this game is awesome some guy says
the graphics are worse than PF one which
I don't see how he sees but remember we
dream as well you're never gonna see
what you would have if you're seeing it
in real life on like a good PC
watch out those guys that way that way
up to your right oh there's so many
honey what sorry like I had a
flamethrower or something
I'm just surprised they didn't both guys
them die because you're shooting them in
the head oh that guy's gonna get killed
though Oh
hey Bible verse well there's another one
there that's a tank I'm getting Private
Ryan vibes by yourselves squad your last
slide well yes yeah go raise your friend
where no no I'm saying that guys died
trying to read this right oh you're
gonna go friend
sorry I meant like you baited that guy
to go Res
oh yeah he killed him yeah wipe their
spot and then I was just trying to tell
you to like camp the crap out of it so
that they could spawn on you that tank
was being a jerk though your good buddy
always a moment of suspense when you're
getting your ass in this building and
you're reviving someone it's like am I
gonna get shot like that guy right there
to your left that was dumb
man yeah that one this one said all
headshots should be one hit that was
well I definitely I don't lined up yeah
a helmet but yeah that's the only thing
I could little three four three four one
special here hi would you like to wake
up hi would you like a revived hi would
you Eva nice squad ones are worth more
double double D worth time ramanga says
again so I keep doing the good work I'm
out subscribe for sure cool thank you
for subscribing thanks for tuning in see
you next time for all the people that
didn't know if you if you haven't
subscribed yet you should so that you
get notified as to when we go live and
also for all the cool features and all
that stuff that we do live in every day
at 11 for GameSpot daily where we give
you the biggest news stories and 30
minutes or less for the day and then at
11:30
we have GameSpot live where we play some
of the newest games alphas betas that we
get into as well as other fun stuff so
check us out if you have time if you
want to if you want to keep hanging out
with us Lucas
I think it's fine you Oh Lucas oh so
glad you can revive other people that's
his friend probably it's like Aaron
would revive you
you know alright we're going we're
making a big play here for B two squads
making a push for be here and remote
buzz died behind you
[Music]
hey guys I just sucked in like the
videos at Francesco Costello great work
thank you for all that bread been stoned
it says what's your favorite parts of
the game so far for the guys the
shooting and the movement a shooting
felt good yeah it's been it's been
feeling pretty good I like the like
different angles and like different of
verticality that you can get and just
like the different nooks it's okay your
caption cuz it gets by rank up Lucas is
dead though but you know that guy didn't
revive us so I would be revived him two
wrongs don't make a right
parkour parkour parkour parkour hope you
remembered its Lucas oh no game god I
knew it
I mean what am i doing obviously yeah is
that the East bridge okay Lucas now
Lucas is dead yeah he would be dead but
mofos
and doing some sitting and he died first
does the destruction feel different yeah
I think there's more destruction and you
know there's obviously the rebuilding
mechanic which is kind of nice so like
you don't have those issues in the last
game where if you're trying to take a
flag towards the end of a match it's
like completely level they have no cover
it's up Dan Danube good to see you see
it's people like that that's like you
want them to challenge you with their
like assault rifle while you have a
shoot and an execution right there plus
one all right
someone might pick you up here maybe
oh it's just no fuss now with you Aran's
right there there's 12 meters away it's
not that bad if you can spot on a squad
that fast I thought I saw someone who
just run around near you he's climbing
the ladder
and some guys just gonna rock scheisse
I'm in a bad spot open
no fuss okay you got to the other side
of B this is this is the big flank side
nice I didn't want jinxiu I was like
that guy's got sniper yeah yeah oh yeah
here's that a spot that what's-his-name
loved so much Danka oh yeah you got be
back that's good get back up here jacket
2d from the other side oh you climb the
ladder this time old man
bold
oh not like these well that's never
happened I will say good on you for the
patience for the first shot I really
thought you were gonna headshot him
he looked like a head shy no that's what
I'm saying I'm not that's not a troll'
that that's just me being honest seven
bullets I wasted everything else on that
other guy field surgeon that was that
was every shot I missed looks like that
dude probably was freaking out too when
that happens like and I'm playing at
someone else I just keep yelling you
suck you suck you suck
and then look just don't kill you know
COO I don't think I landed a single
bullet on him
I was I was all snow rob was just kind
of scared making them dance yeah I want
I want to see the man
this is a cool little spot yeah dig this
speaking for machine gun just go into
your little hidey hole so maybe if I
shoot these boxes I can get through
time to take be they'll never know we're
in this little hole here they're gonna
have to fix this you gotta go down there
to fight them guess it's just like
clearly not I don't know how you would
fix that though unless you don't let
people go there sure you to turn it like
the proximity huge because like I think
you're under the bridge I'm under it
yeah yeah just like raise the proximity
range or some like that Oh like the
height yeah okay doing pretty good
you're at 30,000 you know the points so
about ten eleven thousand more will get
that be one yeah don't worry I got I'm
watching it's actually next to your name
to if you're looking for the points Oh
what's good Delta wait what years go
back to be Delta Millia prom with that
that tactic of boner to underneath the
bridges not killing anyone like they're
just gonna be able to take it again yeah
would you rather be a five or bf1 this
tank is not having it oh yeah look at
some cod tactics right there
oh hello oh yes yeah that was way behind
you - yeah unless he's alive or get
pants hurt or tanked yeah that was worth
it though
hundred percent worth speak German
please guten nacht good good good good
dog
danke Schoen shiza be high school and
that's all I got the rocket camera
wasn't first or third person he well I
don't know actually because we died last
time before we could actually see Oh
time for plane up so I can get that tank
what do you see Rob
oh yeah
oh I did it too early ass
normally the sky is where Rob lives but
itchy trigger finger first day on the
job let's try to fire my guns see what
the sky is again arias vehicle hit you
got it
and that's flying you guys have to pick
B again or even B
oh good
see you revived that guy dear right
maybe or he's on the on the on the
bricks see him ups on God I was like why
he's struggling I was like oh he's gonna
call
here we go
turn around you you got B now and D as
our good shape don't know you got to
make a call your squad leader sure
almost be one though Rob like mm okay
cool
what's up SMD with plenty of time to use
it he tried the old duck and staying
tactic it's the old it's like it's like
your tea bagging someone but you're not
because it ruins your aim over here
trying to aim for his head didn't work
out so much Rob with the big bigger vibe
here wall heat they take a
how many come in 250 what what a pro
revive thanks I know how did that
intentionally but that didn't house I
didn't even look like it was down here
it looked like it was on a hill
somewhere else see his name to even do
it no I didn't you just had accidentally
did I accidentally did it Lucas whatever
that was weird clip that I guess Oh
second place yeah Luke is that a your
spots on top yeah dude we're we're a
dope-ass spot man oh nice watch out
there's gonna be a lot of peeps there
can I Drive a tank to prove that their
vehicle says Francisco Charles it's
going well later comrade kind of VF rock
at them b1 we got ready know why I'm
saying yeah I think so or you're very
close if you yeah I know you're way over
yeah 49 where do you where should I do
this I don't know it's got to be CRA
right because they're only spawning
let's go eat and go up here and then do
see alright
I'll tell everyone to go to see I don't
know how you have so many points but you
guys are losing quite a bit actually by
like a hundred tickets it's okay he has
bad aim he has bad aim he continues to
have bad aim
my friends save me
yeah sure looks like it was awesome no
you baited him and that's what it was
doing occasion that is contested yep on
it I don't think anyone's there
whatever
I mean they're all probably at they
might have moved off to D but you're
already taking a see right now someone
say can see he's getting shot at from
somewhere
there's some guys there yeah they're
taking it back all right let's do it up
there's a guy right I had to do this
again
I really hope that's not a bad guy right
in front of you see that guy [ __ ] oh
you're just gonna chill okay no you have
charlie now receive
I hope there's some people left worth it
I didn't think anyone was there still
are you alright we're done what a scream
Wow it's like there it is there I love
the noise in May it was like a like a
pitter of like an engine like wow we are
not giving away codes unfortunately dabs
or slab sorry
hashtag worth 100% we're gonna get
another v1 rocket that's how good I feel
about it right now or you can get the
tank in three hundred three thousand
sorry we got some time yeah you're gonna
be able to get the tank I don't know if
you're gonna be able to call in another
v1 you definitely have to do a bunch of
work to get that done actually you
should just try to find a way to win but
I mean either way we got our highlight
movin yeah Wow holy smokes Batman
it must be catching up to that ocean was
is that like a kill streak uh so what it
is at least right now is like if you're
the squad leader kind of you're able to
yeah you're able to kind of call in
things to help your your team
essentially one of two things currently
in the game is you can either call in a
v1 rocket right or you can bring in a
tank which we can also show off as we
want to because it's technically the
tank we almost have enough points for
your last squad member for supplying not
that that wasn't very much a parent for
you already
all right someone's flying on you see
these planes will really bug out see
that it's like glitching wow that was
just something we're just like kind of
frustrating she's gonna be a fight he
felt close Oh Aaron got him though I
think so maybe you can revive you
assuming he's still had hello nice V one
hit on Charlie this is Ronson come on
rock one M one says a question I hear
some streamers complaining the flying is
very slow is that true well they're not
Jets so another one oh yeah it is
where are you going where are you going
no distracted as I um
[Music]
but that being said I don't ya know I
think this is kinda like I get again
kind of the case with battlefield 1 when
it was in closed alpha I felt like the
vehicles were very janky and finicky and
like beta Jojo they did they felt like
they didn't have much weight namely the
ground vehicle it's like I'm gonna tank
in it like it feels like you can't even
like you're on the edge of your seat
like you got another one I missed it
oh sorry yeah I thought that too Dan the
noob I thought like picks blue was the
explosion that hits that be back but it
was really just a head shot
now it's so the maybe you didn't call it
in maybe I didn't call it now you called
it in
that's awkward I
he's at on Rails is it just like
something that just comes around and
kills a bunch people or maybe Erin got
it notice the Panzer right it's the
Panzer
I still have a chance I'm down about a
hundred tickets
oh there's two guys there hi hello
don't take my uh-oh get baited jebaited
that was the whole plan that whole time
yep maybe see if your tanks there does
he have it or is that the Panzers though
this looks like Aaron right yeah his
Rasmus I don't want to be here no that's
that that's isn't that the one oh no
it's not there's a vehicle right there
that was a tank no time check hey watch
me okay totally get you guys
[Laughter]
Stuka
Stuka be to stoke ah this dog out here
hit enemies there somehow yeah yeah [ __ ]
they like this great dude like even that
like I know which there's a better way
to get more precision on these bombs
perish a drop this missile boys
oh you better drop it now solid pingu
I'm stalling
where are we going Rob I don't know
nailed it hit it someone for 20
get some that's another one of those
things another yeah yeah he said he
called when I shine it it kept follow it
follow it into the crack
there's two in the sky damn Oh at least
we got that that squad wipe with the v1
that alone was worth it and I was pretty
tired Oh men what cap that you got the
last two minutes no I don't know maybe
maybe not I forgot to bring a black
magic I don't know why you don't just
use shadowplay so Joey does well I just
having so much fun I forget about it
well that's why you just let it go and
then at least at the end of it you have
the whole thing anyways great job Rob
thanks here yeah you're welcome
thanks everyone for tuning in to the
second day of or day two battlefield
closed alpha stream I think it it ends
was it one day I think they're saying
it's like Tuesday's day so you never
know maybe you'll see another one on
Monday maybe you won't but uh thank you
guys all for tuning in thanks for
playing Rob thank you Eric finding my
spotter you got it
any any other thoughts today as compared
to yesterday or kind of kind of the same
for you yeah it's kind of the same I'm
having a good time shooting feels great
movement is speak to hack attack I'm
gonna play a little more over the
weekend I think the plan is next week
whenever this closed alpha closes we'll
do a video kind of like of our
impression so if you're interested in
hearing more about that then stay tuned
to getting spot yeah definitely we'll be
back at 11:00 on Monday with GameSpot
daily and then 11:30 with GameSpot live
so come back if you want to hang out but
thank you guys all for tuning and have a
good weekend yeah good rest of your
Friday yeah see ya see ya
[Music]